okay so welcome to lecture number 17 uh
let's more or
less go from where we left off last time
so the objective in the last lecture was
to use
Transformers so let me use this so use
Transformers to do operator learning
right so I'm not going to reiterate what
operator learning is we have been
looking at that for last 10 lectures so
but the idea why we wanted to use
Transformers is to scale right so this
is the the keyword here is
scaling so you want to scale with
respect to
data and with respect to model size so
overall with respect to computer so
that's the objective now right and we
started in last lecture by giving you
some ideas of how this works and this
was the let's say summary slide summary
box so your input or input embedding the
doesn't really matter let's say that
this is your input
function uh V of X because we can
interpret all these operations in terms
of uh operators right Me Not In terms
just of matrices or of functions between
vectors and vectors but as operators
between functions and functions so we
needed some positional encoding in order
to because otherwise everything is
permutation and variant and then
essentially the there were only three
elements three three Essential Elements
there is MLPs which were here there are
norms so this was the layer Norm that I
just described in the last lecture and
the most important element of course is
attention right and this is where let's
use this perhaps so this is the element
that was the most important and that's
sort of in some sense a new element when
it comes to Transformers and just to
reiterate what that is again at the
level of functions even though
everything can be done with respect to
to discrete quantities functions on the
grid so what you get is that attention
has this single head attention
multi-head attention is just summing
over over all the heads so you get this
structure here so essentially what you
do is that uh you it's sort of um Point
to Point connection if you want to think
of it that way perhaps with uh putting a
picture so in other words you have this
point you have this what what to call
tokens or values at these points so
let's say that this
is something like
this and then you have uh the same
points again because we want to indicate
connections and you can just imagine
that this is your VK this is your VJ and
so on and what attention does is that it
uh in order to update the value at this
point you look at the sort of of
relative information that each of these
guys throw throws to this point right so
this one this one this one so on so
everything is thrown out here and then
the idea is that you take a relative
weightage of how important the
information from all these points are
okay and this relative waiting is done
through a softmax which is in the
integral version it is given by this
term here and in the discrete the
quadrature version is given by this this
classic formula here so in some sense
attention is a very very intuitive
mechanism because it just takes into
account correlations or relative
contributions of different parts of the
input to the output that's that's the
huis thing and it is easily seen when
you when you do this means when you
think of it as a kernel because in
contrast to fno CNO and so on where all
the time whenever we do the work at the
level of uh functions operators we have
to do some sort of Kernel operations so
for CNO we know that the kernel itself
was translation inv variant and it was
sort of a fixed kernel it was learnable
kernel we infer the col from data but
during the inference for instance uh
this is not the case right it's just
something that has already been there
here on the other hand because we take
into account the relative relative
contribution of each each of these uh
tokens each of these points then what
you end up is some sort of a nonlinear
data dependent C okay so perhaps I
should use the word data
dependent so this is why in some sense
Transformers has some desirable
properties that you will see here so
this is the way to think of it that
instead of having a kernel that is uh
inbuilt that is something that we give
using some prior knowledge for instance
the inductive bias that is used here is
translation uh invariance equivariance
right uh that's why we take this sort of
a what xus Y type of Kernel on the other
hand here we have no such inbuilt
implicit biases or inductive biases what
we have instead is that it has to learn
it from the data okay and we offer it a
lot of scope to learn from the data
because as you can see there are lots of
um all all data points make a
contribution it could be that the nearby
points make much larger contributions
than the far off points that's the
structure of the data in that case you
can imagine that you're slowly hinging
towards this right because here it gives
more weightage to the neighborhood
actually it gives all the weightage to
the neighborhood then to the others
right but in some sense you can see
intuitively that if that is the case if
that there is more weightage to the
neighborhood all that it will do is that
the attention the relative attention
weights for the neighboring points so
let's say these three points would be
almost 100% and the rest fall up very
very quickly so you can somehow recover
this locality also from having this kind
of a global structure but of course in
some other problems perhaps this is not
the right kind of an inductive bias then
it is able to leverage it is able to
sort of understand this and should be
able to learn so this is some let's say
very rough heuristics into why of course
it was proposed more from the
perspective of language where if you
think in terms of language uh attention
makes a lot lot of sense right in vision
and in pdes it's a little bit less but
if you think of it in terms of a
nonlinear kernel then of course the
intuition becomes in some sense stronger
so this was the sort of the key element
right uh this was the key element and
the rest were of course some details
because as you can imagine that uh the
other elements were like pointwise
operations MLP lay normalization and in
some sense they are not the essence of
uh attention a sense of attention is
really this ense of a transformer is
really this attention block here good so
now that seems all well and good but
there must be a caveat right the fact
that we are allowed to be so General
that we can interpret local locality we
can interpret Global Information so on
we should pay a price and what is the
price that we pay remember that I
already alluded to it that in order to
compute this relative weights we had to
do another loop here right so we had to
go again and then compute the tension
weights by doing a so we fix this point
and then again we do a broadcast so
essentially all these points make a
contribution and then you compute that
so you here you have K operations or k
tokens here you have K more tokens so
you have this quadratic complexity and
this is exactly what I wrote down here
that in terms of the number of Tokens
The cost is actually quadratic so the
compute in the even just one single
inference remember that the with respect
to machine learning algorithms there are
two distinct processes there is
inference and there is training so
inference is when you deploy your
architecture right and this is during
training what you do is that you
repeatedly Loop over keep on inferring
through all the data set that you have
right so there is a so training of
course is much more expensive but uh
these are not completely unrelated to
each other right because during training
you have lots and lots of inference
rounds so now how does the compute look
like so essentially this can be computed
uh it's rather straightforward to
compute I could have gotten some uh
something wrong but the key Point here
is that it's quadratic in the number of
uh
okay so this has serious implications of
course remember that we also have some
input features and this is the hidden
Dimension so hidden Dimension was uh
here right so this q k and so on if you
remember the query for instance is a m *
n Matrix so what you do is that you take
information from n dimensions and
typically you lift it to n Dimensions uh
the other way around you start with n
dimensions and you lift it to M
dimensions so you can think of M being
much larger than n perhaps not much
larger but certainly larger than n
because it's a lifting Dimension a in
space in some sense so this is of course
also quadratic in the number of features
but that's uh less mild compared to the
number of tokens why is that let us
imagine that we are talking about um
forget about the weather but let us take
a very very simple situation we have
fluid flows incompressible fluid flows
so now stoic equation so our unknown in
some sense is the velocity V and this is
two components the X and Y
component and uh so in 2D it has two
components so this means that n is equal
to 2 even if M was equal
to 100 or let's say 10 okay because I'm
just putting some numbers here usually
it's not 10 it's more closer to 100 then
it is to 10 but let's say that it's 10
so this you can see is just 20 it could
be 200 it does not really matter now
what is the number of tokens so remember
theistic that we have now is that if you
think of an image in
2D so we have an image so this is the
domain then each point corresponds to a
token right because in each point the
point value at that point corresponds to
a token there are two channels let's
forget the channel Dimension because
that is included here but uh so there
are how many points now in 2D so it
depends let's say say that we do some
let's even take 128 squ right so 128
squar is 2 to the power how much is that
so 2 to the 7 so 2 to the 14 right 2 to
the 14 is a very very big number already
so that's the number of
tokens okay K is 2 to the 14 because
each of these points uh gets expanded
into a line right so you have 2 to the
14 tokens so what is the complexity now
of a single INF run is 2 to the 28 so it
is 20 * 2 to the 28 now 2 to the 28 is a
very big number I don't even want to
imagine how big it is right roughly
speaking it is 2 to the 28 is like 10 to
the it's three so 10 to the 9 it's more
than a billion right so it's more than
already more than a billion which is a
which is a very very it's it's big this
is just in 2D at a low resolution now
just scale the resolution up and just
let's start doing some numbers if you're
in 3D and you're at 128 cubed then all
bets are off right because now you can
see that the number of tokens K is uh 2
to the 21 right no isn't that correct 2
to the 7 cubed is 2 the
21 and uh the number of parameters the
the number of total number of the cost
in terms of the number of tokens is 2 to
42 and that is uh you're talking about
trillions already right so this is even
for the even for the biggest machines
that are available there these are still
forbidding numbers okay so this is it's
okay because the point where
Transformers were very good was for text
in the in the beginning you only had
text and you know that text uh spoken
text or written text this is not very
rich information because this can be
stored with a very few number of tokens
usually there are these embeddings uh
bite pair word piece and so on and these
store it in very you even the whole of
human knowledge as encapsulated in
Wikipedia for instance is not that many
tokens you know in terms of tokens but
as soon as you come to images and as
soon as you come to sort of scientific
data sets which are more closer to
images and even videos three-dimensional
images and so on you get into problem so
this is uh this is the problem with
Transformers right because they have
this quadratic cost and that can hit you
hard in some cases of course there is
also a way out and the point about
Transformers is that there is Extreme
parallelism what does it mean
parallelism means that different
processes during computation can be
chopped off and this can be sent to
different parts of the processor
different threads different gpus whatnot
right and in fact it's very easy to
calculate this that there are exactly
order of one sequential operations
nothing depends on anything else so in
particular if you think of the
operations here or let's take the
operations here because this is the
expensive one right MLP and uh layer
norm and so on these are very very easy
operations these are pointwise that is
nothing nothing that is happening as you
can imagine here for each of these
points or whether here for each of these
points we can we could have computed
things in parallel there is no
interaction between them right we could
have taken the query you would have uh
applied it onto the vector and we could
have just done it for each of these
points independently of each other and
similar all these operations are only
things that depend are the computation
of the keys the computation of the
values these are all can be done
independent of each other only when you
take a DOT product have you got to
combine them right but that's not a very
dot product is a easy operation compared
to the actual computation of this Matrix
Vector products and similarly softmax
can be computed all the all the things
that go into the softmax these
exponentials they can be computed
completely independently of each other
and they just have there is one
accumulation operation so you can
imagine that there's a lot of
parallelization
and this is the reason why even though
the compute can be expensive you can
parallelize and uh you can extremely
parallelize and that's why Transformers
works so well because you have this
parallelization features that that I
explained and also there is a concept of
path length that I don't want to go into
any details it says that in the same
round you can go from any point to any
point so paath length is how well are
different parts of a computation
connected to each other we know in
Transformers every point is connected to
every other point or every every Point
including itself so of course there is a
unit one path length so it's very very
easy to leverage those those those
facilities yeah so the parallelism helps
but it doesn't help if you still have
100 trillion uh computer sies right so
there is a limit to so in 2D potentially
you could get away but no one does that
even for images no one does that because
uh you don't want uh you don't want this
large computational volumes so we need
some sort of that's why it's sort of
attention pointwise attention is this
would be considered still infeasible and
perhaps unnecessary also because uh you
don't need that kind of local
information after all the difference
between text and image or text and
scientific data sets is that if you
think of um this room for instance and
we are interested in temperature in this
room there's some much more regularity
in the temperature in this room there's
a lot less variation between the
temperature here and temperature here
compared to temp of course you can argue
compared to temperature here and far
away right so there's a lot more
regularities so you could leverage those
regularities it's the same with an image
when I look at you guys there is much
more regularity than at a pixel level
than it would be for instance when I'm
talking because each of the words that I
say there is no regularity as such you
know there are discrete events in some
sense so we are going to leverage those
regular I ities that these data
structures have in order to reduce the
cost of computation and this is what
I'll try to do for the rest of the
lecture today are there any questions
about the computational aspects or what
are the computational challenges of
Transformers no it's
obvious
good let's move
on so one possible solution which is
widely used in Vision uh because Vision
has exactly the same problems remember
that the inputs of images is what is
called Vision Transformers so this was
actually proposed by some mostly people
sitting in Google at zc and this is
called Vision
Transformers and let me explain what it
is and then we can look at some of the
details so the idea is to use images as
the main sort of uh concept here so
think of an
image
so po drawing
it will serve the
purpose and uh you can think of a domain
a computational domain and you know that
at the end of the day things are
discrete so there's a bunch of
points at which we are going to sample
the solution
right a bunch of points at which we have
the image
represent something like
this usually 128 squ 256 squ 52 squ and
so on the idea as I said is to leverage
regularity the fact that locally things
change slowly but of course if you
accumulate these changes over global uh
scales spatial scales then there'll be
large of changes right so the idea
behind this people who proposed Vision
Transformers was very simple that why
don't we divide the domain or divide the
image into what are called patches so
what humanistically what it is is
actually very very simple writing it
down in formulas is a bit some but so I
divide it into blocks or
patches I've just done a very very crude
approximation of it right so instead of
looking at these uh how many points did
I draw 20 points I just look at in this
case six patches this just some numbers
that I'm throwing here right so six
patches and the idea is that there's so
little variation within the patch
there's so much of regularity within the
patch that I could essentially instead
of having these four pixel values I
could replace them with a single uh
feature a single attribute from the
patch or single feature single attribute
from this patch single attribute from
this patch and so on so by dividing into
patches instead of having 20 potential
tokens I went down to six tokens of
course this process scales just imagine
if I have 128 squar image and each patch
is 16 by 16 and this was typically what
the original Vision Transformers paper
resolved then instead of looking at 128
squared Point values I I simply look at
128 divided by 16 squar and that is 64.
vales right so there's a dramatic
reduction in the number of tokens all
that you Leverage is the fact that
neighborhood information is taken into
account that things are don't vary
dramatically within the neighborhood as
you would expect also Solutions yes
James multi like Fast multiple
[Music]
yeah it's a very simple partition of
unity type uh idea in some sense
right multipole is a bit more
hierarchical this is much simpler
because when for those who know multiple
methods or these are called tree methods
anyway so there is a hierarchy where uh
you leverage the hierarchy you don't use
any such deep sort of you could do it
you could also patch based on on that
kind of a featurization but this is a
much more naive way of doing because you
see that multiple would work very well
if you have a lot of regularity right
then you can just cut off some some
parts here images and solutions to very
complicated pdes they have some
regularity but they don't have that many
that are jumps and so on that probably
it's just as well to do this okay so
let's let's try to look at some of the
map so the idea is very simple right
that you just uh take this
non-overlapping patch
and in each patch you aggregate the
features of these nearby tokens uh
nearby points let's say and you form
them into this so-called visual tokens
okay so each of these guys is a visual
token visual token it's like a word you
know token is roughly a word in natural
language processing so it's like that so
the key key point is this patch
formation
sorry let's use this so this is patching
and I just explained what that is by the
way I made a mistake here H equal to W
just for Simplicity all of this can be
done with unequal scied images there's
nothing nothing fancy here so now you
pick up um patch size P by P as I said
16 by 16 was a default choice in the
numerical examples that I'll show you in
the next lecture we would use 4x4
because we expect that for Solutions of
PD the patches are to be even smaller
but anyway so the so you have so you
have n patches
so you can imagine that if H was 128 and
P was 16 then this is a severe reduction
okay so instead of having 128 squar
which is uh 2 the^ 14 tokens you'll only
have 64 tokens which is which is much
much easier to work with right and then
the point is that this is where do we so
there could be a loss of information
right so the loss of information could
be from the fact that okay you're just
cutting off the image into discrete
points and then so what means you're
losing information also you're
essentially taking averages right but
what you do is that always in machine
learning you learn something you learn
some additional features you say okay
let me learn the best roughly speaking
there a heuristic right there's no
guarantee that that heuristic is taken
care of during the Ping process but let
me learn uh instead of just taking an
average of these four points which is
what I could have done this the easiest
aggregation that I can do let me take a
learnable uh sort of feature uh
extraction okay so I what does it mean
roughly speaking is that you take
weighted
averages you'll see when the operator
version comes in the next next slide you
take some sort of roughly speaking
averages means uh with shared weights so
the patches are so it's the same
features that are being learned the same
types of features that have been learned
across the different patches and then of
course each time you embed it into a
Laten dimension
plus some latent
embeds there always that uh okay we lose
some information because we are taking
into account the regularity but perhaps
we keep that information because we
projecting into a bigger space this is
always the trick right also with the
remember with the unet architecture this
is what we did we courent we down
sampled but we increased the number of
channels because there we could we could
learn something and remember that the
the sort of the increasing the number of
channels would have been a very very
mild operation because this is this is a
very mild thing to begin with right so
even if I go from 20 to 120 it is
nothing like the 2 to the^ 42 numbers
that we saw with the number of tokens so
this is what what happens here again the
detail is not not that important so what
you do is that you you extract this
local averages so these are the local
Point values they just B together into
into this uh into these objects and then
you embed them into a into a bigger
space so these are some learnable
embeddings so at the end of the day
instead of having an image you have and
instead of taking every single Pixel and
laying it out as a very very large uh
Vector large sequence what you do is
that you do this in this clever manner
so each of this is the same embedding as
you can see so that as I said the
weights are shared it's like a local
average so think of this V1 V2 as local
averages weighted learned averages with
the the same features that are being
extracted across each um each patch for
instance right so the advantage now is
that we have exactly end tokens we have
reduced the computational complexity
considerably and at the same time
hopefully by taking this learnable
elements we keep some of the information
that is that is that is available and
these are the things that are fed into a
Transformer so the Transformer remains
as before that it is going to attend but
now what it is going to attend to is
different earlier it would have just
attended every every single point value
now it is attending this learned local
averages okay so there is a subtle Point
here and this sort of becomes very very
clear one so at the end of the day if
you think of it realistically all that
you are left with are these tokens so I
just Bunch these things
here and I have extracted them of course
the channel dimensions are different
right so instead of just temperature
pressure humidity whatever it has 20
different parameters which are
supposedly learning some features that
are lost while patching patch F now
these are very very simple heris in that
sense it can be written as operators
means this is exactly sort of justifying
what I have just said that you do this
you divide the domain into this
non-overlapping equal patches if
possible it may not be equal but that's
a simplist then you take weighted
averages across each patch and these
weights are shared right and then
finally you sort of embed them into a
into a latent Dimension so this is
roughly what this form indicate as I
said the emphasis is to aggregate
information while at the same time
keeping some of it through additional
channels okay so the htics is very
simple these are very very easy to
implement operations because all that
you do is you just multiply right kind
of matrices or tensors based on uh the
right kind of embedding Dimensions that
you take so is pafic pacification clear
the mental image that you should always
keep is this that from this complicated
image you come to to a simple sequence
instead of coming to a much longer
sequence that would have that would have
happened right any questions about this
yes still need
a we absolutely need a positional
embeding you cannot because now
this it is still there is some some
information there's some inductive bias
I will talk a little bit about it in
fact that was the next slide right so
okay let me let me get to it so that I I
discuss we still need to add positional
embeds because there is no sense of once
you put these tokens there's no reason
why I I I just took them in one
particular order right I could have just
uh juggled them around and I would have
gotten s similar thing right so there's
no sense of any kind of position in this
process so what do we do how do we put
position uh we we put learnable ones
just like I explained in the last
lecture actually it's very simple so I
just
append now instead of doing last time I
said the most General case in MLP but in
practice people use just linear very
simple linear positional embeddings so
remember that this guy
here
sorry so each of these so these are so
this is a vector right each of them is
so there are n of these capital N of
these tokens each of them is I probably
made a mistake with the number of
Dimensions here but maybe not um so each
of this is an RN Vector RN Vector so
these are new
features and then all that I do is I add
an additional piece of information I
append to it an additional piece of
information which simply tells you what
the location where the position is right
so roughly speaking this here which is a
vector which is n cross n Vector so each
of these components so for instance e+
one e+ one is essentially telling me
what is the position of ev1 EOS 2 is
telling me what is the position of ev2
and so on and so forth of course there's
a trivial way in which you can view it
as an operator that's that's not
important it simply tells you where the
thing is inside the D okay inside inside
the which patch does it belong to and so
on and where what is the relative
position of this patch good so you
always need position embeddings you have
the position embeddings you have the new
features the patched features and these
are the ones that you feed into the
Transformer so the WID operator block as
you can see is of the following
form okay so as you can see that you
have this is in 2D you can do this in 3D
also you can not 4D any Dimensions you
can make patches but the algebra becomes
complicated that's why I explained it
simply in Tod
okay so now you have your domain
computational domain you have your input
which I'm assuming is a continuous
function with C channels and then it's a
sequence of operators so as you can
imagine the first step is to do the
patch embeddings so do the patch
embeddings and the positional embeddings
and these are the new set of tokens
right so this is uh roughly the set of
tokens that uh that I just extracted
with the position edic so these tokens
tell you where roughly where these
things are and then you throw them into
attention right so you start by layer
normalization so you normalize then you
put some attention I hope I didn't make
a mistake here I don't think so and then
you do a residual connection as before
and similarly you repeat the process you
again take the output here you do a
perhaps I should
have okay it's roughly don't I have a
picture no but it's it's along the same
lines as before
I should have had a picture I'm sorry so
except that now you have the input
embedding is in terms of a patch this
the patch
formation okay and then it's the now the
the order of these things is reversed
you know so the norm comes first and
then it's attention Norms come first and
then it's attention and these are simply
to do with how well gradients this is
empirically observed that in some cases
putting the norm before the attention is
better in some other cases putting the
norm after the attention is better and
this keeps on changing based on the
architecture so there is this there's no
no no sort of uh proper way to say which
is good and which is bad because this is
uh whether you normalize and attend or
whether you attend to normalize you
should roughly be in the same order
right but the difference now is that in
terms of the gradient propagation
because one has to train these
algorithms there could be some marginal
differences so that's that's a detail I
just want to give you what uh what
people have done in this in this regard
right so okay where is it
now here so as you can see so you start
with your input uh so let let me write
it down so you have your input then you
do
patch then a layer Norm right so patch
layer Norm then the multi-headed self
attention right and then the input uh
plus the residual this is your new input
and then this goes through uh so this is
a plus then it goes through uh layor
again then an MLP so this is an
MLP and then again
another uh plus here and this is your
final output so this is how it looks
like right I should have I should have
drawn this before but you get this you
get the sense and you have to stack
several of the yes
uh is that correct let's see so what is
V hat now V hat is just the input of the
patching oh yeah of course yeah I always
make this mistake also last time there
was a mistake right okay good uh because
I prepare these things late at night and
I myself not having the full
concentration but good you're right of
course everything is done in terms of
patches so at the end of the day you get
features per patch so the very final
thing you have to extract things at the
level of the image but that is a very
very simple upsampling operation right
so you just have each patch and you have
to get the local information to each
point so again reverse what you did when
you did patch formation right so in
terms of matrices this is very
straightforward I think in the next
tutorial they are going to teach you
guys how to code up a vision
Transformers so you you'll learn it
there so what is the computational
complexity now and then uh where do
where do we stand Vis comp computation
complexity the point is that again I
have given in terms of an image but you
can imagine in terms of a function
defined on a grid right so the
resolution is here and the compute uh
just in terms of number of tokens right
I've forgotten the fact that you have so
many channels and so many features and
so on those are not important the
dominant cost is given by the number of
tokens so if you take a standard
Transformer pointto Point Transformer
then this would have been my cost right
and just imagine for 128 by 128 image
this is quite expensive right but now if
you if you have patches then uh this is
much better so let's do the math here so
you have 2 the 7 * 2 7 squared so this
would have been 2 to the 28 right but
now when we do the patches so you have
uh 2 to the 7
so okay there the same number 2 to the
28 but the patch was how how much did I
say 16 right so 2 to the 4 so 2 to the
16 so this becomes much more manageable
right so 2 to the 12 is a very very mild
number so it's not a lot of computer so
of course it it really so as you
increase the patch size it's very very
clear that uh the compute becomes better
however there is a Twist here right and
what is the twist as you increase the
patch size okay you can take the whole
image as one patch so at the end of the
day each time you do patching you lose
information you're trying to recover
that information by adding additional
channels and so on but you can imagine
that if I had a 4x4 patch there would
have much better representation of the
function then I would have taken a 16 x
16 patch right so there is always this
uh tussle this push and pull dog of war
between computation and accuracy means
you want the things to be
computationally feasible which would
mean that you want large patches but at
the same time you want uh reasonable
amount of accuracy so you can't have
very very large patches so by for some
applications like in imaging and so on
it is okay because at the end of the day
uh a lot of Imaging is about
classification you see so you just look
at the image and you
identify boy or girl in our case it's
only boys here so it's very very easy
right but men or women but then you
could have
uh so in in the classroom of course and
then uh this is a very very easy
classification it doesn't require a lot
of detailed information about the face
and so on however if the there was a
much more quantitative question being
asked like what would be the temperature
given a certain amount of pressure then
can we really go to 16 x 16 patches or
32x 32 patches it becomes harder and
harder right so it depends on the
question that is being asked so for most
Imaging applications uh 16 by 16 is a
very good patch size but just
empirically you can imagine that uh if
you want to do temperature calculations
or structural strength calculations and
so on 16 by 16 is not so good and we
have to reduce the patch sizes to 4X 4
or 8 by 8 and then again the computation
scales up because just by taking 4x4 I
would have gotten another factor of 64
here and that's a big number you see so
this is in some sense doesn't scale for
the applications that we have so what do
you do when you have relatively smaller
patch sizes we have another trick of the
of the sleeve and this is the one that
seems to at the moment work the best let
me just briefly describe it because I
have five more minutes and in next
lecture we sort of focus much more is it
a very interesting and a very natural
idea very recent uh in in imaging of
course all these ideas come from vision
and then we we just reiterate and
recycle them for our purposes so this is
called windowed attention is there are
many many ideas means there's axial
attention there is
uh shifted attention there there all
kinds of long attention hierarchical
attention but I think this is the
intuitively the simplest in some sense
and the idea is that you go to another
level of complexity or another level of
representation and work at that level of
this was introduced approximately 2
three years ago by two two and a half
years ago perhaps by some people from
Microsoft in Beijing and the idea is
window detention what does it mean so
remember that this was my original image
it's some sort of a castle as you can
see it's not a it's just at the level of
an image and that's that's good enough
to explain and then what you do is that
each of these boxes here are patches
okay so each of these boxes here are
patches and uh we have whatever number
of patches that are there and when you
do attention all that we do is that we
take let's say we fix a patch here let's
say this patch and then we compute the
tension weights from all the other
patches right we calculate the value
here we calculate the value here of
course we calculate the neighboring
values and so on and so forth for and
this uh particularly if you have small
enough patch sizes which is what we want
to do then this can be expensive and
this is what I just explained that this
can be expensive the idea of these
people was very simple that instead of
doing attention over patch over each
patch to patch instead of point to point
we went to patch to patch now they say
let's not do attention over patch to
patch because that's the expensive part
right because that's where it's
quadratic let's do it over windows so
these windows are an additional layer an
additional level of description of uh of
detail which is that you divide the
image in addition to the patches you
divide them into these kind of Windows
the windows are much bigger so each
window contains quite a few patches
these can be equally distributed in
practice they always are because the
more equal things are the easier it is
to call things from memory to cach
things and so on so you make it as
simple as possible at the level of
computation although in principle you
could make this differenti differently
sized and so on but each of them
contains quite a few number of tokens
let's say in this particular case each
of these um Windows contain 16 patches
okay each of them contains 16 patches
and attention is only happening inside
the window what does it mean that when
I'm Computing the update for this
particular Point here I know that I have
to compute attention right but this
comput to compute attention I have to
compute uh attention with respect
earlier I did it with respect to all
these points this point here this point
here as well as this point here now I
don't need to do this I don't need to do
this I don't need to do this I just look
at the nearby points so the global
information is lost I'm just looking at
local
information like I would do in a CNN for
instance right in in a CNN I would do
exactly the same I'm taking local
information and I'm using that to update
okay so of course this makes things much
easier because now instead of attending
to all the other 63 tokens I'm only
attending to the 15 other or including
itself so 16 tokens instead of 64 tokens
right so and similarly here in order to
compute attention uh I just compute over
all the neighboring points here I
compute over all the neighboring points
here so this is not Global anymore it is
local so we all just imagine in terms of
kernels this kernel has a support inside
the window right and that of course
reduces computation considerably because
because now attention is not happening
across the entire domain it's only AC
happening across this windows and M is
the number of Windows m is the number of
Windows and of course this is the number
of Windows is much less than the number
of patches so of course uh if I have 20
Windows 20 squared is nothing compared
to the total number of patches then of
course the question that you will ask is
okay then how am I ever going to learn
anything about uh then what's the
difference between this and essentially
CNN because at least in a CNN you're
sliding across each of the your window
is sliding so you are sort of uh
intuitively taking care of other points
how do we do that and the idea is and
this is what I finish with okay I I'll
talk about it the idea just to give you
an idea is that across each layer you
shift the window just like uh so okay so
across so intuitively it's very simple
let's say that I was never attending to
these two points uh
but now if I shift the window in the
next layer then what happens is that
this point and this point are exactly in
the same window and if I shift it in the
next layer then two other points will be
in the same window and so on so
intuitively by Shifting the window
across layers in each layer you still
keep it constant but across no one tells
me that the window size should be fixed
across layers you're going to stride
over the whole image okay and this is
sort of the key feature by which one can
attend to all the let's say all parts
representative parts of the image right
but perhaps this requires a little bit
more detail which we will do in the next
lecture but you can think that where
this ideas come from it's the ideas are
rather rather simple and by doing this
rding you reduce the path length across
tokens so you do have a Global
Information propagation by just
harnessing the fact that you're striding
the windows okay simple and a very
elegant idea that that works quite well
okay with this uh let's stop here today
was again this short lecture not very
effective because half the time I'm
reminding what I did in the last lecture
but but yeah so and next Wednesday
There's a holiday we are all supposed to
stop working on that day because of
workers rights but uh but then we are
back on the sixth right oh no third
third sorry okay Chia then